une silhouette devenu célèbre sous le
trait d'hergé pour le château de
moulinsart le château de cheverny attire
toujours les visiteurs
ce matin c'est dans les jardins plus
exactement au potager que se dévoilent
des fleurs à peine éclose c'est une rose
qui porte le nom du château
est ce que vous sentez elle a un parfum
très délicat elle sent bon et latham y
en a beaucoup en même temps là du coup
même si on est un peu plus loin on sent
quand même le parfum un parfum qui
séduit petits et grands et ce n'est pas
la seule qualité de ses rosiers les
pousse très vite son très rustique cd
rosé qui peuvent attendre jusqu'à un
mètre cinquante
c'est pour refléter l'âme de son château
que constance de vibrer s'est mise en
quête d'une rose qui porterait son nom
j'ai flashé sur la rue château de
cheverny parce que sa couleur était déjà
très étonnante
et surtout elle a une odeur
extraordinaire qui est un mélange des
pistes vanille et 2 t de fruits
voilà très agréable et enfin elle est
très résistante
une rose née ici dans l'allier chez le
rosiériste georges delbard
l'aboutissement d'un long travail nous a
fallu huit à dix ans pour la regarder
l'observer pas ce que je fais là voilà
on vient la voir on la regarde à
différentes étapes de sa vie mais aussi
du climat de la saison pour voir si mais
à chaque fois elle nous montre qu'elle
est toujours la meilleure et qu'elle va
satisfaire le jardinier une fleur élus
rose de l'année 2021 par la société
royale d'horticulture de londres le
graal dans un environnement très
concurrentiel où plus de 40 mille
rosiers sont proposés sur le marché
mondial l'enjeu est de créer chaque
année de nouvelles variétés de roses par
hybridation un mariage qui nécessite
plusieurs étapes bien déterminé là je
suis en train de prélever d'étamines
d'une variété mer qu'on a choisi pour
ensuite la pole et miser avec une
variété plaire qu'on aura aussi choisi
selon des caractéristiques bien
particulières pour créer ensuite une
nouvelle variété de rose et puis vient
la pollinisation
un geste qu'il faudra répéter jusqu'à
1500 fois par jour pour obtenir le fruit
ou se développeront les graines
dans la nature ce sont les abeilles qui
font le travail
elles viennent chercher le pollen d'une
rose et vont le déposer sur le pistil
d'une autre c'est ce que peuvent
observer les visiteurs des jardins
d'europe l'un dans le loiret
je trouve que les roses anciennes ont un
parfum qui est plus délicat et qui est
comment dire plus durable la passion des
roses
stéphane chassine la vie depuis la
création de son jardin il y a vingt ans
sur un hectare on trouve plus de 500
variétés de roses
ainsi on retrouve beaucoup de variété si
on pousse et d'août sont principalement
des rosiers lianes car ce sont les
rosiers qui donne le plus de fruits et
donc il se ressèment dans le jardin la
terre est légère donc ça puisse très
rapidement et qui colonise où les arbres
ou les pergolas sauvages ou cultivées
discret ou éclatant les rosiers vont
encore embellir nos jardins jusqu'à
l'automne